これは遮断ですね うんうん
ここもいいですね まだちょっと
で まあ一応そんな感じになります
この番号とテキストの番号がちょっとずれるかもしれませんだけど
それはそんなに問題ないんです
一応 まあこういう風に過去分身があって
これ読み方は同様 分身が同様して
それから分身は遮断にしますと
本当はその瞬間に遮断してるわけじゃなくて
次にはもう分身がないんだからもう遮断というだけ
ものすごい即的な言葉なんです
で このこちら に比べて
こちら過去の分と言うんですね
じゃあそこでこの 第3セッツナで右分身が終わりますて
第4セッツナでもう右分身が遮断されて
その代わりに五蘊陰転が生まれる
そこで五蘊陰転生まれたということは
この情報が眼耳鼻舌身意どこから現れたかなと心がそこに引っ越しするんですね
その場所に このチャンネルの方に引っ越しちゃったら
それは目に入った情報だから
目で生まれなくちゃいけない
そこでチャックヴィンナーナという心が生まれるんですね
そこでチャックヴィンナーナが生まれた
いわゆる目に心が入っちゃったんです
今心はこのワンセッツナ目にいるんです
こんなセッツナなんです
チャックヴィンナーナ
その 1セッツナ終わったらこの心は死んじゃうんです
死んじゃうんだけど まだこの物質は体に触れてるんだから
そこでエネルギーが入ってるんだから
6番目のセッツナでサンパティッチナという心が生まれるんですね
サンパティッチナ サンパティッチナ
受受心という よく使っていた心がありまして
受受心が生まれるんですね
いわゆる受けるんですね
受けたということ 心にもう入っちゃった情報が
いわゆる心がどうやって受けたという
この振動を受けちゃうんですね
目に触れた振動が心に受けて心も振動するということなんです
で この物質の世界で考えればすごいわかりやすいことで
で 私は例えばあの 私のところにある机とそちらのある机のちょっとつなげておいて
この机を叩くと その前の机も振動しちゃうんですね
別に私は叩いたものがそこまで行ったわけじゃなくて
この振動を次の物質が受けて
その振動を次の物質が受けて受けて
そういう風に連続していっちゃうんですね
まるっきり同じものじゃないんです
ここまで説明すると難しくなるかもしれません
適当なところでやめないと
えーと いわゆるこの外の世界で起きてるこの出来事
外の世界で信号が振動が起きて目に触れている
目は振動している 目が振動していると心がそこに行ってその振動が受け入れる
でも物質の振動と心の振動は同じですかと
全然同じじゃないんです
例えば私は手で何かドラとかシンバルを
ありますね シンバルっていうんですか
あれ 音楽で使う そう シンバル
それを手で殴っちゃうと
そこは私の手の振動を受けるでしょうね
受けて自分がはい分かったと反応する
その場合は音が出るんですね
そこで私は同じ手で同じ反応を机に入れちゃうと
机もその振動を受けて反応するんです
でも その時の音は違うんです
そこで私は同じ手を水の中にドーンと同じぶん殴っちゃうと
すると水も反応するんです
でも 水がする反応とシンバルがする反応は随分違うんですね
ですから 受ける側が自分なりにそれをコピーするんです
だからコピーしたものとコピーの原稿が同じじゃないんです
ただ似ているようなだけなんですね
もしドラムを叩くスティックでシンバルを叩く
ドラムを叩く あるいは楽器を叩く
ギターがあるんだったらギターのスティックで叩くと音が出ますよ
でも ドラマーだったら同じ強さで叩くことできるんですね
僕らにはできませんだけど
ドラマティストだったらきちんと同じ力で
もう1時間でも3時間でも叩くことできる
そこであなたは同じ力でドラムを叩きなさいと
じゃあシンバルを叩きなさいと
じゃあこのギターの弦を叩きなさいと言ったら
ドラムもシンバルもギターも同じエネルギー量を受けちゃうでしょうに
受けちゃうんだけど それぞれものの反応が違う
そこで同じ速さで机を叩いてみてください
同じ強さで私の頭を叩いてみてくださいと言ったら
頭も反応しますけど でもシンバルほどの音もほとんど出てこない
そういう風にこの そういうコピーシステムですか
そこを理解してほしいのです
このエネルギーの流れのこの働きが
で それを物理学と全く同じものなんです
我々は携帯電話で電波を出すと
そこら辺の宇宙空間もそれを受けちゃうんですね
携帯電話で自分が音の振動を出しちゃうんですね
そこでマイクロフォンがそれを受けちゃう
マイクロフォンが自分なりの振動で受ける
それは自分なり それは周りにあるいろいろコイルやら磁石の磁場やらね
そういうものを受けると
それからそれは電子 電子信号になっちゃったりして
それはアンテナに受けられると
アンテナがそれは宇宙空間に出しちゃう
出しちゃうと瞬時に多次元に広げちゃう
そうすると どこら辺のアンテナがそれを受けると
そのアンテナが私の声はまるっきり受けることはできない
そちらにできるのは この宇宙に広がっている電波に反応することだけ
そのアンテナを通って
そこから機械通って そこからまたいろいろなものを通って
また新しいアンテナからそれを発信すると
発信すると 受ける側の携帯電話のアンテナは
その宇宙空間に流れている振動だけを反応すると
それでまたどんどんどんどん変化していって
スピーカーで空気を振動すると
空気を振動する時に限って人間の耳が反応すると
だから決して相手が喋ったことを音を聞いてるわけじゃ全くないんです
携帯電話聞いてる私がこの耳の中にある音の振動だけ聞いてるんです
自分の携帯電話のスピーカー作ってる振動が
でも我々はそういう過程は全部もうなしにして
何々さんの声だとすぐ決めちゃう
そこ仏教で間違いだと
それは それは原因であって
こちらにある結果ですと
それは過去のことである
もう終わってるんだ 喋って終わらなかったら音入らない
で そういうもう大変複雑なんですけど
でも事実ですからしょうがないんです
そこでこの心が自分なりに振動を受ける
このサンパティッチャラの場合はもう心の世界
ナーマの世界 それはあんまり明確にアビダンマでは言ってないんです
本当は慰問で生まれるはずなんですけどね
あまり言わないんです
で いわゆる老寿審が生まれると
振動はサンパティッチャラ
次は何でしたっけ？ サンティーラとかのデータから推測する
確定は推測で確定しました
覚醒の作用などは 疑問だから共因体心で確定ですか？違うわ
ごめんなさい 間違えた
老寿審が次  確定作用は
推動心ですね こちら書くと面倒くさいんだから
作用で 作用で言えばしょうがない
サンティーラが次 それで確定してる
推動心 すいません  そこまでですね
それで で こう考えましょう
いきなり心が瞬間引っ越しして目に生まれる
目に生まれら一刹那はチャック・ヴィンヤーナと言うんですね
眼識と言うんですね そこで次の瞬間心が死んじゃって老寿審という風に生まれるんです
そこはどこに生まれるかというと
それはもうほとんど場所がないと思いますけど
心ですからね いわゆる振動を受けちゃう心で
次にまた心は刹那しかいないんだから
次の刹那で推動心になっちゃうんです
前の振動を受けて 次の心で違う振動を起こしちゃう
それはいわゆるどこを行こうかなという風に何とか推動する
どんなものかなという感じで
はっきりわかってない状態なんです
そこで確定する あ こういうものやと決めるんですね
次のウォッタプの心で
いわゆる目に触れた あの目にぶつかったの情報が目にぶつかったの形がこういうものやと決める
で 決めたものとぶつかったものはまるっきり同じになって
それはそうじゃないんです
心は勝手に決める で 弱い心はそれなりに決める
強い心はそれなりに決めると
大体そうでしょうね 例えば赤ちゃんが何か見る
子供が何か見る 青年が何か見る
若者が何か見る それなりに違うでしょう
同じ絵を見ても 同じもの見えません
振動送るの心だから 一応確定するんだ
まあこの場合はそういう複雑な説明を抜き抜いて一般的に考えましょう
例えば花でしたと 花でしたと思ったら花ですよとここで確定する
確定したところで心が
六回七回 七回 七回ジャガナという働きがするんですね
心がここで受けたし 確定した振動によって同じ心
振動が七回ぐらい起こるんです
これは即行とか言ってジャガナってのは僕はこの前なんか違う言葉で説明しましたね
どんな言葉で使って  波です
いわゆる反応 反動 反応みたいなものなんですね
ですから その確定心で確定心は強い心だから
すごい振動を持ってるんだから
その振動によって次に同じ心が七回生まれると
その七回生まれてもエネルギーとしては波なんですね
こうやって いわゆる走り出したところは強くないんです
次に強くなって 次に強くなって
次に強くなって だいたい三番
四番あたりは結構強くて
五番 六番弱くなって 七番目ですごく弱いんですね
いわゆる九 九番目の接触などでジャガナが即行心が生まれて
十番目はちょっと強い
それに走ってる心から振動送るんだから
十一番目は結構強い 十二番目はもっと強いかもしれません
それで十三番目はもうエネルギーがなくなっちゃったから弱くなったんだと
十四番目はもっと弱くなったんだと
十五番目はまあ弱いんだと
それ以上は動かない 走らない
で あれはあの手で何かビールなんか回る時も同じでしょ
一回目はそんな強く回れませんだけど
二回目は簡単に回る 三回目はもっと回れると
四回目はもっと回れると
そうすると ある程度手で回るビールをこれ以上回れないというところは出てくるんです
いくら頑張っても それで回ること止まっちゃったら
自分で回転してゆっくりゆっくり回転して止まると
その時間はもう一応決まってるんです
物質の世界での 手でホイールを回して最高スピード出せる時間と
最高スピードから普通の停止状態に戻る時間というのは大体決まっている
で 即行心が生まれると
で 私たちは言ってるこの妄想の世界というか
考える世界というか そういうのが一応即行心なんですね
でも考えるの目では考えることはできない
この場合は この場合は見るだけですから
そこでどこで見たんですかね
はっきりで言うと アビダンマでは眼識で見たという思ってるんですけど
現実に考えちゃうと 見たという認識は持ったからもう見たんです
そこで見たものについて即行心七回生まれるんだから
そこで感情が生まれるんですね
いわゆる綺麗な花だったら
もうそれに引っ張られるし
汚い醜い花だったらそれからもう離れちゃくなっちゃうし
その人間の好き嫌いの心がこの即行心なんですね
例えば花を見たとすると
花を見てあ 綺麗だと思う感情が生まれたら
これはどうせあの 邪悪な心は何ですかというと
あの貪瞋痴の八 貪瞋痴八がありますね
貪瞋痴の八の一つなんです
どちらかと言いにくいんだけど
で もう嫌な花ですから
見たくもないものでしたら
えーと 瞋恨心の二つありますから
それ二つのいくつかなんですね
大体は  終わって それ終わったら心がもう走ったでしょ
走って止まるんですね
止まっても なんかあまりも走ったんだから急に寝ることはできないんですね
急に寝ることはできないんだから
ただランマ  二つ書くんです
ただランマ それあのただランマでのこの可笑縁と書いて
この可って書いてるのは可でもいいんだけど
このこの目に入った情報のことなんです
それによっているんだという意味だけなんですね
で まあそれぐらいの意味
で 一応五蘊心ではないと
それはこの何心でしたっけ？意熟心ですね
で 例えばきれいな花だなと感じたならば
その味わいみたいなもの
結果 まあそれもっと即的な例えでいいんです
例えば喉が渇いていると
何か美味しい飲み物を飲んだと
飲む瞬間で あ 美味しいということがあって
飲むともうなんとなくああ良かったという感じが生まれるでしょ
あれは味わっている状態なんですね
飲む時は美味しい それだけ
ああ良かったというふうに落ち着く瞬間なんで
このただランマって で
本当に飲んでる状態は邪悪な状態なんですね
飲んで この一口飲んだとしても同じこと
一口飲んで あの瞬間で
ああ良かったっていう感じが出てくる
それがただランマの可笑縁という心なんです
だから可笑縁はいつでも意熟心なんですね
そこでこの説明すると
かなりのアビダンマの基本の知識は必要になっているんです
なぜならば 意熟心になる意熟心は何でしょうかと
可笑縁の働きをしてくる心は何でしょうかと
即行心の働きはどんなどんな心しているんですかとか
そういう勉強はもう頭になければ
こちらに言ってる哲学は入らないんですね
だから私はそのアビダンマから出ている哲学を言おうとしたら
また初めから全部言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
でもこのワンセットで
人間の心の働きは全てまとめて説明しているんです
こんな短いこと でもこれだけでは絶対に人間理解しないので
それの膨大なアビダルマ知識が必要なんです
これどういうことかというと
この目にものが触れても
初めはただ寝ている状態だけ
そこで第四刹那のところで目が覚めると
第5番目の刹那で これ目に心が移動して
その反応のコピーを受けるんだと
それで心自体が振動を始めちゃうんです
見たという振動が その振動によって
これはどんな振動かなと
それで推導すると 次の刹那で推導したものを確認すると
確定すると 見たものを確定する
確定するんじゃなくて
推導したことを確定するんです
で 自分勝手に確定したものに過ぎて感情が走っちゃう
そこで善行為も悪行為も行うんです
善悪感 見たものとは本当は関係ないんですね
ですから それで感情が生まれたら
よかったか悪かったかのどっちがなんとなくほっとする瞬間が生まれると
結果として 例えば怒りが生まれたら
なんかちょっと悪いという感じが生まれるし
欲が生まれたらよかったという感じが生まれるということですね
それで必ずその即行心は欲か怒りかというと
そうでもないんです 善心も生まれる可能性あるんです
だから花を見て欲が生まれるか
怒りが生まれるか 無智が生まれるか
あるいは善心生まれるか
善行為をするか それはこの人のやり方次第
そうしてその心の中にあるまま勝手に流れるものですと
という説明しにくいほど難しいことを言っているんです
だからそこから人はものは見ているんですか？とかね
我々は考えられる いくらでも
実際に我々はものを見ているんですか？聞いてるんですか？直接ものを見られますかと
見られませんね 結局は直接
我々持っている心という
このものがそれなりに反応する
それはもうあのスティックでものを打つと
反応はその打たれるものによって変わるんですから
ですから 目に触れる情報は誰にでも同じですが
それで心の反応が人によって違うと
私は一本の花を見せると
皆様方は同じ花を見るんだけど
皆様の心に起こる反応がそのその人によって変わるんだと
そこで 見たらね 嫌なものを見たら心が汚れますよと
これ見たら心が汚れますよと
これ見たら心が清らかになります
みんなよく言ってるでしょう
世の中で あれ見るな これ見ろとかね
あの本読むな この本読めとか
なんか物に当たってるんです
でもそうでもないんです
例えば子供たちは見ては
まあ日本ではあまりないんだけどね
外国に行っちゃうともうすっごい厳しいんです
この本でも内容でも扱う使う言葉でも厳密でももうチェックして
子供に悪い影響を与えないようにとかね
日本であちこちあるいろいろ漫画とか雑誌とかね
新聞あるでしょう あんなもの持って自分の国に行っちゃったらもう捕まるんです
見つかったら大変なんです
たまに車自体没収するんです
この間インターネットで見たんだけど
なんかどこかでこの外国関係の会社でね
工場で仕事している女の人と夫二人ぐらい
この何て言いますか このポルノ雑誌をいくつか外国のもの車で持っていて
まあそういうもん遠いところで見つかって
警察に車ごとに没収 大変なことですね
まあそれでアメリカでも同じでも
そこら辺では大変厳しい決まりとかいろいろあったりして
その考え方っていうのは
物によって人が悪くなるというふうな考え方なんですね
でももっと一歩進んでみると
物によって悪くなるかと
例えば同じ まあ例えば人の裸の絵かもしれませんだけど
子供が見たら心が乱れるかもしれませんだけど
これおじいちゃんおばあちゃんが見たら
まあ全く面白くも何でもない
もうなんだこれという感じなんですね
それで それでもおじいちゃんたちがいるんですね
すごくこのよだれ垂らしながら見ているという
子供たちみたいに だから問題はこの物体にあるわけじゃなくて
人の心の状態にある そこでまあ外国で言ってるのは
子供はまだまだ何も経験なくて
世の中何も知らないんだから
心はもうなんて言いますか
あまり傷がないんだから
やっぱり外の情報で心はしっかりするまで守ってあげようと
そこで大人が見ろと言っちゃったら
必ずそれ子供まで行ってしまっちゃいますから
大人にもやるなと もう厳しく
決まってるだけのことですね
ですから このどっちが正しいってことじゃなくて
例えばだからといってね
まあ平気でも何でもやりなさいと
見るあなたが悪いんだと言ったってもそうでもないんですね
我々の育ち方によって
我々はそれなりの影響を受けるんで
それはどうしようもないんです
ですから 育ててない場合は外の方でもコントロールしてるし
心が育ってくるとコントロールはいらなくなるんです
心はしっかりしているんだったら
どんな醜い汚いものを見ても大したことはない
で このこの恐怖映画ですか
このグロテスクの映画なんか見て
なんかものすごく怖くなったり
もう汗が出たり 毛が立ったりする場合もありますね
一人一人が でも落ち着いてれば何のことなく
スクリーンで出てくるものを言ってるだけで
見られていることもできるし
それから僕もあの 昔もう年ぐらい前
あのエイリアンという映画のビデオを持っていて
向こうの子供たちはこっち来いと
あんた方に映画見せてあげるからと行って見せたんだけど
こいつらもう 4 分の 1人も見なかったんですね
子供たちが怖くて 一人の子がやっぱりもうテレビを好きで
もう見たいんだけど これ怖いんだから見ないんですから
出ていかない 後ろ向いて
後ろ見ちゃって何の意味もないんだけど
やっぱりもうそれ見て
私は別にまあもうこの子供たちの反応は可愛いんだからね
ある子はもうよく見ていて
ある子はもう見ない ある子はこうやったり
半分見たり ある子は全くもうあっち向いているとかね
一人から逃げるとか で
別にまあ大人にとっては何のことはないしね
映画のからくりやら作り方やら
なんだかの知ってる人にとっては何のこともない
面白くない くだらない物語なんですね
ですから このやっぱり心を育てていくと
外からコントロールはいらなくなる
私 そこまで言ったらこの戒律ってのがあるんですね
仏教で なぜ戒律はあるかというと
心は弱りと仮定しているんですね
心は影響を受けるんだと
心はすぐ誘惑されるんだ
それだったら外で一応壁を作っておこうと
それで心ができたならば
あの壁の意味は全くなくなっちゃうんです
もう誘惑されませんから
例えば綺麗なものを見ると
どんな人の心にも欲が生まれてくる
貪瞋心が生まれてくる
そこで出家の戒律の出家の戒律も何億もありますから
五戒ぐらいじゃないんですからね
もう随分きめ細かくきめ細かく
ものすごいたくさんあるんですけど
そこでも例えばものを見るとどう見るべきかと
それは明確にもう分析してあるし
異性の人を見ると まあ自分の年と同じぐらいの人だったら
まあ妹かお姉ちゃんだと思いなさいと
自分の妹お姉ちゃんだと見ると
欲っていうことは生まれてこないんですね
もっと年上の人だったら
まあおばあちゃんとお母さんだと思いなさいと
誰見たってそういう風に見なさい
そうするとね 若い出家者たちには心から欲が生まれることは何のことなく
どんな異性の女性の方見ても妹さんかお姉ちゃんかお母さんかっていうおばあちゃんとそんな感じなんです
だから僕らのこの普通の仏教のの決まってる言葉ありますね
我々喋る場合は全部そういう兄弟の呼び方なんですね
信者さんもそういう兄弟関係で呼ぶんです
で ですから どうせお寺に来るの年上のおばあさんたちの方が多いんだから
僕らの言葉ではいつでもお母さんということはいつでもあるんですね
お母さんたちというふうに人を呼ぶんです
で それはもう決まってるんだから
まあだいたいそういう人を見てるのが
すぐまあそういうふうにお母さんという感じも生まれるんですね
結局は で それからまあ妹にも当たれないし
お姉ちゃんにも当たらない場合はどうしますか？と
おばあちゃんにも当たらないし
お母さんにも当たらない時もありますね
まあほとんど同じぐらい見るなと喋るな
ですから向こうは別にそんなに厳密じゃないんだけど
だいたい自分の国だったら他の国は知りませんだけど
だいたい同じぐらいの女の人と喋るとすぐ長老たちがものすごい怒るんです
この野郎何やってるんですか
部屋に行けと ほんでも元気すらどうですかと
怒られる怒られる それとももう年が離れてる場合
別にもう気にしない そういう風なこの決まりがあって
それはいつでもこの心が育てていないということ
心が弱いとすぐ誘惑されるんだと
すぐ間違いを起こす可能性あるんだと
ですから育てるまで大事に守りましょう
この植物を植えるとき
我々同じことやっちゃうんですね
小さな植物を植えたときは
日本ではどうかわかりませんだけど
日本でも同じことでしょうよね
冬の場合はちゃんとビニールテント張って守ってあげたりするし
雪の場合もそれなりにいろいろなことをして守ってあげたりするし
虫から守ってあげたりするし
そこで一人前になったらあれは全部外しちゃうし
自分の国でも小さな植物を植えたら必ず全部隠しておくんですね
なぜならば植物に日が必要なんですけど
この弱いものに強烈な日が当たっちゃったら死んでしまっちゃうんですね
ですから もうほとんど日が当たらないように隠してあげて
動物に食べられないようにいろいろなことをして
そこで大きくなったらあれは全部外しちゃって
どうぞ自由に頑張ってくださいと
だから弱い時は守ってあげる
ですから そこで戒律というものができているんですね
その中でも種類あるんです
戒律 一つはいくら心を育てても影響するんだと
もう一つは心が育てたら別に影響はない
二種類あるんです 戒律
どういう 例えばどういうこと
例えばわかりやすいのは酒
随分心を育てて まあ立派になっている人がいるんだと
瞑想が進んでいて その人を騙してでも
何かにいろいろ入れてでも酒を飲ませたらどうなるんですか？心を育ててるんだから酔わない？そうないでしょうに
一旦体に入ったらもう心
酔うという現象が生まれる
それなりに他の人と違うかもしれませんだけど
それでも知識あるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり酔うという現象が生まれるんですね
ですから そういうこの心は育てることには関係なく
外から入ったら影響するものは
もう一応悟り開いたっても
もう気をつけなくちゃいけないと
罪を犯すことにはなりませんだけどね
自分では飲もうとしませんから
騙して飲ませることできます
でも騙してでも 例えば阿羅漢になった人を騙して酒を飲ませた
いろんな工夫をして 飲ませたら一旦体に入っちゃったら体が酔った状態になります
それは大変な罪なんですけどね
飲ませた側には 阿羅漢ですから
悟ってるんだから別に自分が罪を犯したことになりませんだけど
体が弱くなるということは確実にあり得るんですね
そこで出家にはこの性欲ですか
そういうものはもう何の条件もなし
やめなさいと それは別にそんなことあったって心汚れませんよという人々がいたんですね
言ったらお釈迦様の一言が
じゃあ欲の気持ちがなければ性行為できますか？性行為するためにまず欲の心が必要なんです
だからまず心を汚す それから行動をすることだからありえない
で いまだにこの密教仏教のあーだこーだとかね
かじった もうかじってもないんだけどね
ちょっともう舐めようとしている人々がね
随分言ってますけどね
そういうことじゃないんですね
それは出家の場合 在家の場合はそこまで断ってないんだけど
でも性行為の場合は まず心は欲の気持ちが生まれて
それから行動に行く ですから
阿羅漢になった人はいくら誘惑があってもそういうことはしない
しないというか どういう言い方ですかね
わざとしないんじゃなくて
ありえないということだけど
心は汚れませんだから
行動は起これません でも
例えば悟った人がいて
随分体が弱いと で 医者がこの体には栄養必要ですよと
で 決めたら それだったら適当なご飯はいつ食べてもそれ構いません
それは体別に汚すわけじゃないんだから
ただその物体を維持しているだけだから
で また他の医者が来て
あなたはもうずっと生まれてから性的な行為をしていないんだからダメですよと
健康に悪いんだと やりなさいと言ったら
でもそれはダメと ありえない
医者がいろいろチェックして
あなたはまあ貧血ですよと
栄養失調だよと いろいろもうこれではあなたのこの吸収の吸収力もないんだと
あなたはもうこれぐらい
これぐらい食べ物はこれぐらいの量で
これぐらいこの回数食べなくちゃいけない
それは別にそれに従っても構いませんです
そういうふうにこの戒律論というのはとんでもない難しいんです
だから戒律だけ勉強する
で それ一生終わっちゃうんですね
ですから 昔はこの教の専門家
戒律の専門家 アビダンマの専門家と
もう別々に学派に分かれているんですね
一人に全部できないんですから
ものすごい難しいんだから
ものすごい膨大な量だから
ですからこの勉強の場合は
私個人の意見で言えば
戒律の学問はそんなに難しくないんだけどね
法律ですから 法律的な立場と
この心理的な働きだけちょっと束ねればササササーッと勉強できますけどね
でも